Hi!
(audience loudly cheering)
Thank you so much-
How you doing?
For coming on the show.
We were so excited that you are here
and before we start, I have to ask what your message is
to young girls like you who have a dream
but don't know where to begin.
Follow your dreams,
Break those glass ceilings, be resilient,
be strong, and you'll get there.
Oh, Chef RO, I mean, you really are the example.
So it's really amazing to ask life advice from you.
Okay, will you take us through what we are making today?
The title is my favorite.
So this recipe is called Don't Be a Jerk
and it's basically a crab cake
that I marinated in jerk marinade seasoning.
And why is this dish meaningful to you?
So, I was raised by a single mother,
I don't know my father,
but what I do know is that he's Jamaican.
So I just really wanted to tap
into the Caribbean side of myself.
I love it, okay, we're really excited
to learn this meaningful, personal dish
from you that really is original.
So teach us, Chef RO, what's first?
Yes, okay, so, easy,
I have my crab meat in the bowl, all right?
I have some lemon juice in there ready.
I'm gonna add my one egg to it.
The egg is gonna be kind of like a binder.
I have my beautiful pre-made jerk marinade in here.
This is gonna be the seasoning to our crab cake.
It makes it extremely moist.
It makes it extremely spicy.
So we want to add all of that in there as well.
Of course, Ritz Crackers, Ritz Crackers are my favorite.
So the Ritz give it some texture
and it also gives a little bit of sweetness
because that jerk is so spicy
because of that Scotch bonnet pepper.
So I got all of my Ritz in there
and of course we're gonna season this
with some salt, give it some love.
I finish it with some black pepper.
And then we're gonna mix this all together, Drew.
So I have my gloves ready.
If you want, if you have a rubber spatula,
if you want to get in dirty with your hands,
it's all up to you.
I do have a rubber spatula, RO.
I actually just made it and it says,
Make Something Beautiful, Love, Drew.
Oh, I like that, I like that.
So I'm just mixing this all together.
I'm using jumbo lump crab.
So you don't really want it to be shreddy,
but you just want to mix it together
so everything holds together.
So what I have here is my pre-made crab cakes.
Okay, I used a ring mold,
just because I wanted the crab cakes
to be the same size as my Hawaiian toasted rolls.
Once it's formed in the ring mold,
you're gonna take it and you're gonna put it
on that plate of panko.
And that's gonna be like the extra crispiness
on the outside of our crab cake.
So I'm just gonna take this
and move it on-
Yup, so with your hands,
you wanna push out, yeah, you can do that.
You can slide it right on there and then use your hands
to push it out of the ring mold.
Exactly, and then slide it up, perfect.
That's exactly what I did.
For the home cook to do such a professional
restaurant-level like move like a ring mold,
it's really exciting.
And then do I want to add the panko on top as well?
Yes, so I put panko on top
and then I flip it over just to kind of press it down
so that it has this nice coating.
And then that's gonna stay in the refrigerator
for about 30 minutes minimum
or overnight, ideally, so that the egg binder,
the Ritz crackers, everything can just solidify together
so that you have a beautiful crab cake.
So we're gonna go right into our, I'm using corn oil.
So you want to go until it's golden brown and delicious.
So about 30 seconds on each side.
So, Drew, Drew,
once you get golden brown and delicious,
I just want to come and I want to blot this
on a paper towel just to get that excess fat off, okay?
I'm gonna land right on the bottom
of my Hawaiian toasted bread.
So what we did was we made a jerk mayo,
because I like my sandwiches with mayo.
I made the mayo from scratch.
So I had my oil, my one egg yolk,
and I added some of that jerk marinade
that we made in the beginning for the crab cake
and I'm just gonna lightly put this on top of my bun.
And then a little tomato.
Would you like me to put-
With whatever you want-
The crab cake first?
You can get creative here.
Exactly.
Chef RO, how would you like me to pile?
In what order, bread-
It's all up to you, Chef.
This is where your creativity comes in.
You can use any kind, anything.
You can use onion, you don't have to do onion.
You can do whatever you would like.
You can do pickle, whatever you prefer.
So you make it how you would like to eat it.
I'm gonna say that I really am piling on.
I like the accoutrement, I like onion
and I like what feels like a restaurant burger.
And I can't wait to try this crab cake.
Okay, here I go.
You ready?
You go for it first, let me know.
Oh my gosh.
This is incredible.
This is the best crab cake I've ever had in my life
and I'm a crab cake fan.
Oh, thank you, Drew, thank you.
I really appreciate that.
I'm glad you liked this, Drew, thank you.
Chef RO, I'm so honored.
Do you think we can do this again?
Listen, call, call me, I'm here.
It's a date.
It's a date, Drew, I'll see you soon.
(Drew lightly shrieks)
(bright upbeat music)